we've got a really important message for
anyone who's looking for work
or is receiving unemployment benefits
the time is
now to find a career let me repeat that
the time
is now in nevada federal unemployment
benefits expire the first week of
september
and when september 4th rolls around
that benefit is over we have no control
over any of that that means you have two
months
before the extra three hundred dollars a
week goes away
that's not a lot of time and that's a
lot of money
that has to be replaced it will
disappear
we urge you not to wait until the last
minute
to look for work dieter reports
that the number of weekly unemployment
claims
continues to fall and that's a good
thing
because right now we have employers who
need you
this opportunity is a time when there is
success just waiting for you to expose
yourself
to the experience that we're going to
have here this is going to be an
incredible experience we know that there
are a lot of reasons why people may not
have returned to work
so far some have left their jobs
some have had time to re-things as a
result of the pandemic and may have gone
off in a different direction
others may well be dependent upon
the unemployment benefits but
it doesn't really matter why if after
september people who would not otherwise
have the opportunity
want to work now is the time
and the reality is that replacing
the three hundred dollars is really
going to be consequential to families
and individuals who've needed that those
dollars so
this is the time this is a really
critical
wonderful opportunity i'm here with
commissioner
ticks agribloom who is co-hosting this
with us
and let me introduce him to you
thank you jim i've never had an echo
before so pretty impressive
i just want to point out that there's
going to be over 100 employers
we have 2500 rsvps so far but we're
looking at between 10 and 20 000
actual jobs that will be available here
on friday
so anyone who is interested if you
really want work you know dress
accordingly come down and meet people if
you just want to check out the job
market you can
but when we asked these employers to
participate we said first do you have
10 or more jobs and second are these
well-paying jobs we don't want minimum
wage jobs
so these are actual jobs that if in your
field
or maybe you want to try to switch
fields and check it out but but these
jobs are worth coming to check out
this is the las vegas market as mr
gibson said
uh in a couple months these jobs will
not be available and unemployment may
run out so
now it's a perfect opportunity for
anyone looking for a job anyone who
wants to
hire somebody to come down here on
friday morning at nine o'clock
thank you thanks dick we've got a
a flyer that lays out some of the
employers that will be here but let me
just mention that tesla
amazon cvs caesars entertainment mgm
resorts the cosmopolitan venetian umc
anthem blue cross blue shield pink bucks
donuts
pink bucks donuts metro police
pt's pub and sierra gold the list goes
on and on virtually every industry
that has employees in our valley
is going to be participating in this job
fair there's never been another job fair
quite like it
we have we'll have professionals that
will be at the job fair if you show up
and you're not sure of your resume
someone who knows will look at your
resume
maybe make suggestions to you we'll have
laptops and printers
available if you need to fine-tune it or
if you don't have a resume
we'll help you put one together so that
you're going to so that when you go to
your
job interview you'll have an opportunity
to help the employer understand what
your real
experience is keep in mind that this is
a job interview so
dress in an effort to impress the folks
that you're going to be interviewing
with and as was indicated this is a time
when
there will be people who will come here
and bring their resume and dress right
and be interviewed
they'll be they'll walk out of here with
job opportunities commissioner seger
bloom and i
have sponsored several job fairs
and a couple of times we've had people
walk past
fact we had one lady i think who said
she had four
or six or something job offers there
will be
jobs offered people will become employed
this friday at the job fair
so let's let's make sure that we take
advantage
of every opportunity and this is one
great one
it's also noteworthy that the southern
nevada health district will be here
to provide vaccinations to people who
want them or need them and keep in mind
that some employers
are requiring or hoping that their
employees
will have will have been vaccinated i
don't know
which ones require and which ones hope i
just know that the vaccines can be an
issue
if you haven't had a vaccine then come
all three will be available
it'll be free to you and it's an
opportunity to further comply with
whatever the work requirements
may be so we we hope that you understand
that this is really
the the last opportunity to get
these jobs in time to take care of
whatever your budget constraints are
going to be
after the unemployment benefits change